on va d'abord parler du bateau aux chêne
Viking actuellement en mer Méditerranée
qui accueille 234 migrants à son bord
l'Italie refuse de l'accueillir la
question se pose monsieur le ministre
pourquoi la France n'accueille pas ce
bateau dans les plus brefs délais tout
d'abord je voudrais quand même rappeler
que il s'agit d'un drame humanitaire
absolument épouvantable des femmes des
enfants des hommes qui ont été sauvés de
la mort au milieu de la Méditerranée par
cette association et qui cherche
aujourd'hui un port sur pour pouvoir
accoster et pouvoir sauver en fait ces
personnes après il y a des règles le
droit international l'Italie elle-même a
signé un certain nombre de conventions
internationales qui l'oblige à secourir
les bateaux qui sont dans ces eaux
territorial ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui et donc c'est à l'Italie
d'accueillir ce bateau et pas à la
France et c'est donc à l'Italie qu'il
revient d'ouvrir d'ouvrir ses ports il y
a des mécanismes aussi de solidarité
européenne qui ont été mis en place
notamment pendant la présidence
française de l'Union européenne qui
permet ensuite de répartir les migrants
à travers à travers l'Europe mais cette
ça a été ne peut s'exercer que si les
états s'engagent à respecter le droit
international et leurs obligations
européennes mais parmi
[Musique]